who's going to pay $5,000 for a purse
turns out your average stupid American
who gets a stimulus check for 3600 bucks
isn't going to put that into their Roth
IRA they're going to put that on a purse
or a trip to Miami or go somewhere on
spring break we always say this that the
money is going to flow to the top people
aren't just going to take this free
money and invest it in their 401K not
going to happen they're going to ball
out they're going to ball till they fall
they're going to try to keep up to the
Joneses they're going to basically try
to fake it till they make it and that's
how you have Bernard Al no the owner of
lvmh BEC a the second or first richest
man in the world cu the average person
that's getting these stimulus checks is
just going to just spend all that